pas garder vos nostalgie de ce monde un
peu égoïste sûrement mais est très
intelligent à ses superbes
oui sûrement pourquoi pas je veux dire
c'est un monde ne pense pas qu'il y ait
suffit pas de le juger il faut aussi
pouvoir le raconter et pour le raconter
il faut l'avoir connu il ne s'invente
pas alors c'est pour ça qu'au si je fais
le rat je fais le rapprochement avec les
cantiques et n'a jamais n'a jamais renié
ce monde jamais au contraire il a exalté
à un point tout son oeuvre et
l'exaltation avec un esprit critique
très fort et avec cette affreuse
inquiétude que l'on sent chez l'odeur de
dire si je ne parle pas de moi là je
parle de l'auteur si je me raconte pas
qui saura / eu ce désir de témoigner de
dire nous vivions comme cela le décor de
notre vie c'était ça ou l'abondance des
détails voilà le côté inventaire entre
les charrettes qui sont peintes
c'est très beau